When you're sculpting your terrain,
the standard circle brush is very useful.
However, there are gonna be instances
where we would like to have more control
over the brush that is used.
And particular, what we would like to do
in some instances is actually have a brush
that resembles some type of landscape feature,
some type of natural feature that we can then use
to paint these features or apply these features
to our landscape.
And we can do this with our brush type being set to alpha
and then setting our texture here to an alpha brush
that we have imported.
Now, before we go any further,
let me show you what this actually can do.
So if we come over here, look at this.
This is alpha brushes in action.
So here we have on the left-hand side,
just that single alpha brush.
And we've used that to create this one mountain here.
And then if we use a combination of this brush
in different areas and click at different strengths,
we can actually get something like this
that resembles a mountain range.
So let's pop over to the editor and see how this works.
So first, once I get inside the editor,
I'm actually gonna come here, I'm gonna disable my fog
so it makes things just a little bit easier
for us to see.
And then I'm gonna activate, well, before I do that,
let's just hit control space really quick
and make sure that we have this brushes folder
and we have our impact craters and our mountain.
We did import these at the beginning of our tutorial,
but if you haven't, all you need to do
is just simply grab these from the folder
that accompanies this tutorial
and then drag and drop these right
into the content browser.
You can put them inside of a folder called brushes
or you could just leave them
in the root of the content folder.
That is entirely up to you.
With those imported though,
what I'm gonna do is come up now to my landscape
and we're gonna come over here,
make sure that sculpt is selected.
And then in our brush type,
we're gonna change this from our simple circular brush
to our alpha brush.
When we do that,
we're gonna get a bunch of different brush settings.
So really quickly, we have the texture,
which is going to be the T mountain.
So we're gonna use that
and we're gonna use this selected asset
from content browser.
And then underneath this, we have a few other options.
So we have our texture channel,
which allows us to change the channel
that is sampled from.
So this means that we can actually store different masks
or different textures inside of the R, G, B
and alpha channels of a texture
to give us more flexibility out of this one texture.
For now though, we're just using the red channel
because we only have one mask.
We then have our brush size,
which is gonna control the size of our brush
that we edit the landscape with.
And you can see it kind of right there.
Then we have use clay brush and auto rotate
as well as a texture rotation.
Now for us, what we're gonna do
is I'm actually gonna disable these two
and I'm gonna take my brush here
and just bring it all the way up to 81, 92.
Now, if we were to go actually a little bit higher,
check this out.
If I multiply this by four,
it's gonna give me a really massive brush,
which I can't actually get by pulling that
all the way to the right hand side there.
So you can get a larger brush.
You just need to increase this brush size
a little bit bigger.
Couple of caveats to this though.
Once you do that,
you might run into instances of your landscape
running very slow once you've clicked.
So just keep that in mind that the larger your brush goes,
the longer it's gonna take to process those changes.
Now, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna come over to an area like this
and we're just gonna click.
And you're gonna see here
that I just start to kind of bring up this landscape
in various different ways.
Now, you can see I'm starting to kind of,
build up some ridges here.
Now, one of the other things that we can do
is I am gonna turn on my auto rotate here.
And auto rotate allows you to kind of have this
texture rotate itself
as it's being dragged along the landscape.
And this is really, really, really useful
as we are trying to kind of get some
different looking data using the exact same stamp.
So again, what this is gonna do
is it's gonna allow us to make things
look just a little bit more unique
and a little less similar to everything else
that's going on around it.
So you can see here, I'm adding some stuff.
Let me come over here.
So there's my camera bookmark one.
You can see by just pressing one or two,
I can really quickly get around the map
and see where I want to add
some of these really awesome
looking little mountains here and there.
Also remember, you can press shift
to push stuff down into the landscape as well.
So we can get some really cool looking divots
as well as some peaks.
So what I want everybody to do right now,
I'll spend the next few minutes,
maybe like two or three minutes,
just experimenting with this
and brushes of various strength and size
and go ahead and try to fill out
some of your landscape here with this brush tool,
allowing you to again,
add some really interesting features.
Now, once we have finished adding some features
with the alpha brush,
the next thing that I want to talk about
is the pattern brush.
Now the pattern brush works in a similar way.
We assign a texture,
which we can then display across our entire landscape
and then use that to affect the highs
and the low of our landscape.
So in this case, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take this image right here,
which is some craters,
and we are going to again, go back to our sculpt tool,
but instead of our alpha,
we're gonna click on our pattern
and then we're gonna assign this crater texture to it.
There are gonna be some similar parameters in this tool,
like we saw in the alpha tool,
but there's also gonna be some things
that are a little bit different.
Primarily the world space, origin,
center texture on origin and repeat size.
What these allow us to do
is control how this particular texture
is laid across our landscape.
And what I mean by that is,
well, here we have an example.
If you can't see this laid out on your landscape,
we can switch over to lighting only,
and then you'll actually be able to see
this is that texture right there.
So what happens when we go to paint this
is we're gonna get something like this.
So we're gonna get these craters
that indent into the ground,
and we can actually paint this
across our entire landscape.
So let's go ahead and look at this in action.
So back over in the editor,
I'm gonna hit control space
to come over to my impact craters,
and I'm going to put those as our texture here.
And there we go.
So let's, and we might need to do some stuff here.
So we are going to turn off our auto rotation.
Oh, and I'm on the wrong thing here.
I need to click on the pattern brush.
There we go, my pattern brush.
And that is more like it.
So we're gonna bring this to use world space.
We're gonna set the repeat size here to 8192.
And for having a little problem seeing it,
so I'm gonna come over here to detail lighting.
And there we go.
We can see this just a little bit better here.
So if I was to click on this,
and we'll come back over here to just our regular lit mode,
you can see there are the little divots
or the little craters that it made.
And you can see it's actually made it
across the entire landscape.
So if we were to come here and, I don't know,
maybe like increase or make this repeat size
a little bit larger and come over to an area like this
and click, you're gonna see that the holes
are gonna get a lot bigger.
So you see here, I have some really big impacts.
And then if I was to take this repeat size
and shrink this down,
I'm gonna get these much smaller little holes right there.
So very, very cool stuff going on right there.
So again, like with our last texture input,
our alpha brush,
I want everybody to spend the next few minutes
just adjusting the rotation,
the repeat size and the brush size,
and then coming through and painting on your landscape here
to see the effects that this will have
on your landscape.